Walter pepper and chili Lavinia Billy
Idol mahooty Stevie Wonder opus slowly
top hat right now I think I have about
36 turtles I'm Laurie Kramer
I'm the turtle lady of Manhattan I'm the
only one life rehabilitator in the city
that works just specifically with
turtles I Rehab turtles in an apartment
in New York City bringing turtles into
the country illegally as become big
business
I get turtles from the Department of
Environmental Conservation US Fish and
Wildlife the urban park rangers even bug
policemen last summer I had 680 baby
turtles that were brought here from the
Department of Environmental Conservation
it's overwhelming to have a large amount
of turtles in a New York City apartment
I promised my husband a bathroom and a
bedroom without turtle the back bathroom
is where we take our showers and the
people dancers if I lived outside the
city and I had a yard I probably would
be rehabilitating all kinds of wild
animals but here in Manhattan turtles
are perfect when I was a child there was
no place for women in bed school but
somehow things come full circle I'm a
turtle nurse that's basically it I think
that I get good turtle points in heaven
[Music]
this is the Blandings turtle look
closely because they're hard to spot in
the wild Blandings turtles aren't very
big topping out at around ten inches in
length what distinguishes them is their
bright yellow chin and throat like the
stereotype Blandings turtles take their
time however once they've reached full
adulthood there's no slowing down a
recent study found an 83 year old female
that was full of eggs ready to lay their
general habitat is wetlands with shallow
water
their range is centered around the Great
Lakes extending east to New York and up
to southern Ontario but the wetlands
they call home are shrinking and
becoming fragmented from human
development the biggest threat to the
survival of this gentle and timid
creature this is the Blandings turtle
[Music]
our journey takes us to Costa Rica
more specifically tortuga no to witness
the yearly hatching of baby sea turtles
and meet the people protecting them we
arrived by way of lapa Bona a small port
town with one restaurant and a pay
toilet our boat operator Jairo Guzman
takes a found the lucky river it is a
one hour journey to the island itself
the view is beautiful
[Music]
nearly all species of sea turtles are
endangered and this island is a
prominent nesting ground for both green
and leatherback sea turtles it was here
in 1959 the very first sea turtle
Conservancy was opened by dr. Archie
carp to specifically study green sea
turtles as they were nearly extinct this
was their original base this is their
new base along with us from the
Conservancy is hi Mae head field
director daveed station manager estamos
listos quarter Camille Sylvia outreach
coordinator and their 10 research
assistants they all work here to educate
the public and gather data on the
current sea turtle populations on day
one we meet in the middle of the night
to count nesting Turtles and the eggs
they like now let's go through around
dawn we spot a turtle she's laying her
eggs she is one of 36,000 turtles
nesting this season on the beach each
turtle will lay around 110 eggs in two
months they will hatch we get some sleep
and that afternoon we ask hi mate about
the hatching egg one he says the best
time to catch it is right at dawn around
5:30 in the morning that means we have
some downtime on the island w invites us
to his makeshift office we discussed the
vision of the Conservancy basically we
are working here on the legacy of dr.
Archie car he had this idea of changing
the mentality of the people from
harvesting the turtles for their own
consumption and for making money out of
the meat and the eggs into an
eco-tourism based culture it's a very
complex thing to protect the turtles
on day two the alarm goes off the team
gathers and we head to the beach we are
going to need a bigger boat
[Music]
for a while we see nothing and then baby
green sea turtles begin making their way
to the ocean only eighty percent will
make it out of the nest and of those one
in 1000 make it to adulthood
this means that out of nearly 4 million
hatchlings this season only around 3,000
will become adults and the odds are
stacked against them there's more down
time
on our final day day three we go to the
beach to excavate a hatch nest the
research assistants do this job it is
messy they're counting how many eggs
have hatched in this nest nine did not
make it they'll add this information to
their decades of existing research that
afternoon Cairo's father booth Monsignor
picks us up as we leave tour de Guerre
oh I can't help but think of something
Sylvia said back at the base la isla de
Soto arrows es muy importante para nós
tofu espero también la stotras son muy
importante para la gente que de aqui so
nice Russo muy importante que tenemos
que consigliere tenemos que notre hair
sea turtles are not gonna stop being
endangered this year and they probably
won't stop being endangered next year
either but it's good to know that there
are people out there working hard to
make change happen
[Music]
this is Goliath a Galapagos tortoise he
is massive at over 520 pounds he's one
of the biggest tortoises in the world
Goliath is believed to be in his 80s
galapagos tortoises have been known to
live over 150 years they can go extended
periods of time without food or water up
to a year this unfortunately led to
human exploitation sailors on ships
would bring these slow-moving
defenseless Giants on long voyages as a
source of meat by the 1970s
only about 3,000 were left but through
conservation and breeding efforts there
are now over 20,000 there's become a
flagship species for conservation
efforts throughout the Galapagos but
poaching and habitat loss are still a
very real stretch
this is the Galapagos tortoise
[Music]
you